Salut à vous, qui êtes peut-être sur la plage au moment où je vous parle.
Alors que moi je suis dans la pleine nuit du YouTube Space !
Sauf que c'est un faux décor. Il faut savoir que tout ça est complètement fake.
Ce ne sont pas des vrais immeubles derrière.
Bref, avant de vous donner la nouvelle énigme, la réponse de l'énigme d'hier, énigme que je vous invite à aller voir avant d'écouter la réponse.
Hé oui !
Pour ne pas laisser les éléments qui ne doivent pas laissés seuls ensemble
il va falloir faire des aller-retours avec la barque.
Donc dans un premier temps, l'homme met la chèvre dans la barque. Traverse. Et dépose la chèvre sur le rivage.
Ensuite il revient à vide, sur l'autre berge et il prend le loup.
Il prend le loup, il traverse, il met le loup sur l'autre berge et il récupère le lapin.
Toute la subtilité est là !
Donc il laisse le loup tout seul et il repart avec son lapin dans la barque.
Arrivé sur l'autre rive, il dépose le lapin et il prend le chou.
Il traverse avec son petit chou, il dépose le chou à côté du loup.
Du renard ? Du renard, je dis un loup depuis tout à l'heure hein, on parlais bien d'un renard !
Donc, on sait que le renard ne va pas manger le chou et apparemment le chou ne mange pas le renard.
Il repart à vide et là il va chercher le lapin et il repart avec le lapin.
Voilà la mécanique qui permettait de faire ça.
Mécanique, qui n'a rien à voir avec l'énigme d'aujourd'hui.
Énigme 17 ! [chante]
Je craque alors je chante ! [chante]
Énigme 17 et surtout énigme de logique.
Il y a un homme qui est dans sa voiture, il suit une route, il est dans la forêt, il n'y a aucun éclairage sur la route.
Dans le ciel, il n'y a pas de lune, il n'y a pas d'étoiles, ses phares de voitures sont éteints.
Une dame habillée tout en noir de la tête aux pieds et sur le visage, traverse la route.
Pourtant l'homme freine, ralenti, il la laisse passer et repart.
Ma question: Comment il a pu la voir arriver ?
Vous avez 24h pour trouver la réponse, c'est largement assez.
Je suis quasiment certain que vous allez la trouver.
Dès que vous avez la réponse, ne mettez pas la réponse dans les commentaires.
Mettez plutôt un pouce en l'air, ce qui nous permettra de voir le nombre de personnes qu'ont trouvé la solution à l'énigme.
Passez un très bon dimanche.
Pensez quand même à vous abonner avant de partir.
Voir même de partager une énigme, pourquoi pas !
Il en reste encore 15 pour finir cette série un peu spéciale sur l'été avec les énigmes.
Mais après le Mental Vlog reprendra son rythme habituel.
Avec toujours une vidéo par jour pendant un an !
Rendez-vous demain à 17h !
Ciao !